the u.s navy has officially launched a
ship named after harvey milk a
controversial political activist who
preyed on troubled teen boys and who
defended jim jones another sexual
predator who became one of the most
infamous murderous cult leaders in
american history to top it all off the
official ceremony was presided over by a
man who thinks he's a woman
paula would you please christen the
of the united ship of america
i christen the harvey milk
may god bless the ship and all who sail
in here
[Music]
the usns harvey milk if you think we're
living in clown world you're right i'm
sure our enemies overseas have noticed
that too but
in the spirit of conservative optimism
the knowledge that things can and will
get much worse
mark zuckerberg has just announced that
he is going to create a new virtual
reality where things are going to get
even more clownish and the big tech
oligarchs are going to control
everything i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from jim lubke
who says
this is referring to that weird
microsoft presentation and really a lot
of email signatures now where people
acknowledge that they're on tribal land
quote we want to acknowledge that the
land we're sitting on was traditionally
occupied by the following half dozen
indian tribes and they used to kill each
other a lot this is true when when you
acknowledge that multiple other tribes
in different periods of time have lived
on a certain period of land you're
acknowledging that they conquered each
other
and you say that's all good that's fine
that's wonderful but the fact that we
conquered some land or bought some land
or took some land after other people
left that that of course would be
unacceptable because we're
we westerners we're we're evil but all
the other people they're they're really
really great the country
just seems to be splitting up cracking
up and you're seeing this reflected even
economically inflation going through the
roof which is why now might be a good
time to take a look into acre gold in
our increasingly abstract virtual
dynamic and chaotic world it's good to
hold on to something that has value a
tangible physical thing like physical
gold now you might be thinking well i
can't invest in physical gold because
physical gold's expensive and i don't
have that much money lying around
well i'm here to tell you that acre has
developed this incredible new product
you can start investing in physical gold
for as little as 30
a month yes hold on hear me out
30 a month you send them
your subscription when your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house if you want to up the ante a
little they've got a new 100 a month
subscription to a 5 gram gold bar you
don't need to come out of pocket all at
once to start investing in physical gold
go to
getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url because acre is giving away a
gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre that's getacregold.com
knowles can wles and thank you acre gold
for supporting the show i'm always
trying to look for the silver lining in
things i mean this is this is pretty bad
our country is extremely confused we're
being humiliated to our adversaries
overseas but on the bright side of this
harvey milk ship announcement
the navy recruitment ads are are about
to get way catchier
[Music]
yes
[Music]
i guess this has been a long time coming
you know and frankly frankly
if the navy were to use the village
people as their recruitment ad
they would basically just be doing what
the army and the cia are already doing
with their super woke
recruitment ads this is pretty
pretty weird folks the other thing with
harvey milk by the way what you're going
to hear about harvey milk he was a gay
rights pioneer
he was murdered
martyred really for his sexual desires
and that's not true harvey milk was
killed he was killed along with the
mayor of san francisco by a disgruntled
former colleague this guy dan white who
was upset that he wasn't being paid
enough money to support his family he
just went in and went postal one day in
city hall and he happened to find harvey
milk and he killed him and he killed the
mayor he was not
killed for his sexual desires but
but
the truth will be made to fit the
narrative here okay
that's the power of narrative harvey
milk was a degenerate i mean this guy
would prey on homeless runaway young
boys well below the age of consent and
he would he would
he was a sexual predator toward them he
was a great defender of jim jones who
killed all those people in guyana by
making them all literally drink the
kool-aid that's where the expression
comes from he was defending him to
president jimmy carter i mean he was
just
he was not a good guy okay he was not a
good guy at all
but any and then he was martyred but he
wasn't even killed for his sexual desire
even but it doesn't matter the reality
of harvey milk will be wiped away will
be completely transformed for the
narrative of liberation specifically for
the narrative of sexual liberation which
we're now told is one of the most
important themes in american history
it's being able to sleep with whomever
you want being able to identify with
whatever sex you want being able to
invent a bunch of new genders and this
has now affected the military navy jokes
aside this is this is a new
advancement of radicalism in the navy
now lest you think that i'm merely
picking on the gays or something like
that you were seeing the consequences of
the sexual revolution for the
heterosexuals as well and this is one of
the biggest tabloid stories
of last week it just broke on friday i
guess it was thursday or friday bar
stool sports
dave portnoy who is this
larger-than-life character from barstool
sports and his whole shtick is he's big
and he's brash and he's loud and he's
irreverent and he sleeps with a bunch of
girls and he eats a bunch of pizza and
he does whatever he wants that's his
whole character well it turns out that
that guy
sleeps with a bunch of girls and eats a
bunch of pizza and does whatever he
wants and flies a lot of conventions the
headline from a business insider hit
piece on him is quote
i was literally screaming in pain young
women say they met barstool sports
founder dave portnoy for sex and it
turned violent and humiliating
okay
the peace opens up
with dave portnoy and some chick sexting
right so
uh dave uh and
she messages dave dave says the the
conversation quickly turned to the topic
of sex he sent her graphic videos of
other women he'd slept with according to
madison and in messages reviewed by
insider he pressed her to tell him about
her sexual fantasies
i mean actually this one's kind of
common she wrote like a rape fantasy
where i don't have any control of what's
going on you and i are going to get
along so well he responded so then he
sends her a first class ticket to his
mansion in nantucket she flies out there
and they have sex
and she's much younger than he is you
know she's what 19 or 20 20 years old
and they they have sex and he started
filming her without asking permission as
she performed a sexual act on him
she must have been shocked by this
except she couldn't have been shocked
because he sent her videos that he had
of him doing this to other women
i never said anything i was scared he
was just so mean
and then
i felt like i was just a human sex doll
and
it was so rough
it felt like i was being raped
and then she goes on to describe the the
acts that they engaged in
do you see the problem with this this as
a hit piece as an accusation
it opened up with her saying i want to
feel like i'm being raped
and then
she flew out there and hung out with him
and then she was shocked
when it felt like when he did the thing
she asked him to do
she he just did he just obliged
she said she wanted to do this thing he
did that with her and then she regretted
it
now there's a few layers to this
i don't want to just let dave off the
hook i mean as a legal matter and
frankly even as a reputational matter in
this
decadent
world of the hookup culture and
everything that we're living in
dave portnoy did nothing wrong
right everything was consensual the
woman literally asked for it you know
you're not never supposed to say she
asked for it she literally asked him to
do this
and then
he did that and then she regretted it
but there's a deeper
there's a deeper level here that's the
libertarian level that's the level of
consent that's the level of look they
consented and whatever two people
consent whatever to adults consent to do
is totally fine
right that's the leftist level
i guess now the leftist level is if the
woman comes to regret it later then it's
a crime and you should be thrown in
prison but that's the kind of liberal do
whatever you want just everyone who has
to agree to it but there's a deeper
conservative level which is it's wrong
to do this even if the people sort of
consent
still wrong because there's there's
something beyond consent that there's a
moral standard that is even higher than
consent yes you need the consent but
there's something even if some woman
says degrade me humiliate me do all
these you still shouldn't do it because
it's objectively wrong to do and
i i don't even really blame portnoy here
the whole culture is confused about this
we're saturated in this kind of language
of liberation and consent and the sexual
revolution so we don't even realize that
it's just still wrong to do this and
it's degrading and it's humiliating and
people don't don't even really desire it
there's a difference between what they
think they desire this woman thought she
desired
this rape fantasy and what they actually
desire she hated it when she got she's
like the dog that caught the car when
she got it she hated it
because it's degrading
okay we have a lower will and we have a
higher rational will
and
before the decadence especially of the
sexual revolution we recognized that we
pursued the higher will and we
suppressed all of our
creepy pervy weird urges
but in the sexual revolution we kind of
turned it we turned it completely on its
head
very
and now it's look i kind of feel bad for
portnoy port and i played according to
the rules of the liberal society and now
he's getting burned because the liberal
society doesn't like him
harvey milk rapes young boys it doesn't
matter because he was a leftist and he
works with their narrative and so he's
going to become a secular saint but dave
portnoy he's kind of politically
incorrect sometimes he kind of goes
against the left-wing narrative and so
a reporter is going to spend eight
months digging up whatever dirt she can
find talking to every woman he's ever
slept with and you know what the thing
is
she's gonna get something
she's gonna get somewhere
and and people are gonna feel like the
rug was pulled out from under them well
you gotta recognize no matter what the
don't fall for it don't fall for the
culture of liberation and whatever
people consent to do is fine it's a trap
it's a trick it's not
real
you know what is real rising gas prices
which is why you should check out get
upside gas prices
are going up and up and up and up
well i'm here to give you a little early
christmas present you can start getting
cash back on every gallon of gas every
time you fill up
our listeners are making up to 25 cents
for every single gallon of gas they get
with the free get upside app in the app
store or google play right now using
promo code knowles canon wles
you can actually get using that special
promo code an additional 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up up to 50
cents cash back do not pay full price at
the pump anymore especially these days
get cash back using get upside down the
app for free use promo code knowles
canon wles
get up to 50 cents per gallon cash back
on your first tank some people who drive
a lot are making as much as two to three
hundred bucks per month in cash back
there's no catch the money gets added
right to your bank account or you can
cash out with paypal or an e-gift card
for amazon and other brands download the
free get upside app today use promo code
noles get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first tank that is code
knowles
speaking of sex scandals
former lovegov
andrew cuomo you know the darling of the
left they were they were cuomosexuals
they said during covet
when he was killing grandma in nursing
homes and uh lying about his trying to
prevent federal investigators from
looking into his death numbers and he
was still being fed he was winning
emmy awards
andrew cuomo is being charged
with a misdemeanor sex crime the
misdemeanor sex crime stems from an
incident that apparently took place at
the governor's mansion last year where
he felt up an aide or you know or
something like there had been a lot of
accusations over the course of cuomo's
career that he'd had inappropriate
conversations and pinched his his aides
and all these sorts of things so now
he's being charged with a misdemeanor
sex crime
i don't think this has anything to do
with andrew cuomo feeling up his
secretary i don't think this has
anything to do with democrats clutching
their pearls over sexual misconduct i
think actually the libs just pushed to
name a navy ship after harvey milk a
very known sexual predator i don't think
i i think they supported the clinton
family for decades okay i don't think
this has anything to do with that i
think what this is about
is 2022
and this is where it matters for us
what this is about is trying to take
andrew cuomo off the table and stop him
from running for governor again
that's why i think the democrats in new
york are pushing because there are other
people now
the democrat governor of new york the uh
leticia james attorney general of new
york
uh bill de blasio wants to run for
governor of new york there are other
people who are trying to run for
governor and they want to take cuomo off
the table because cuomo believe it or
not is actually still fairly popular in
new york not popular among
politicians who now want to move on from
him but but he still has pretty decent
approval ratings all things considered
among ordinary new yorkers that's what
it's about and it's why you've got to be
a little skeptical of these accusations
that come out at these politically
convenient times
now
speaking of weird sex so much of our
culture surrounds weird sex
the real big sexual fight that you're
going to see in the next
six to 12 months is going to be over
abortion
more so than usual abortion is kind of a
perennial fight but more so than usual
because we have a big supreme court case
coming down the pike that could overturn
roe v wade and planned parenthood v
casey it could obliterate the fictional
right to abortion that the supreme court
invented 50 years ago
and so all of the legal geniuses are
coming out and arguing no there actually
is a right to abortion here's a piece
that was going around the internet from
the atlantic headline no really the
right to an abortion is supported by the
text and history of the constitution if
the supreme court overturns roe it will
betray this 14th amendment's promise of
bodily autonomy by david h gans
okay so in the
tweet that the magazine sent out of this
article here is the argument
from david gans
the rights to control one's body
establish a family and have children
necessarily safeguard the right to
abortion as a fundamental right
now this is really taking sophistry into
the the realm of the extreme
because
one you know you don't see these these
rights the right to establish a family
the right to have children you don't see
it exactly laid out in the constitution
so surely people do have these rights
and if people have those rights
then
there's really no reason to protect
abortion because abortion negates all of
those rights
abortion
the very rights the purported rights
that this guy is citing to justify
abortion
abortion takes away the right to control
one's body
well abortion
deprives someone of the right to control
his body namely the baby right there are
two bodies involved even abortion
proponents have to admit that they might
say that the bot the baby's body doesn't
really matter or the baby doesn't have
autonomy yet or mom has the right to
kill the baby because the baby's in her
womb there's some of the really sick
ethicists like peter singer have made
that argument what's like a parasite so
you can kill a parasite but still it's a
baby's body so if you have if a human
being has the right to control his body
then abortion takes away that right the
right to establish a family
abortion disestablishes a family right
you are establishing a family but then
when you kill your baby you're
disestablishing that fit so abortion
undermines that right too and then the
right to have children abort abortion
undermines the right to have children
abortion causes you to lose children not
to have children
so
abortion totally negates all of those
alleged rights i bring this up because
you're gonna hear a lot of bogus
arguments in favor of abortion
and i fear what the squishes are going
to do is try to parse all the little
tiny nuances and little details of the
law say well actually you know if you
look at this provision of this
commentary that was written on this part
of roe v wade or planned parenthood vkc
and it's kind of missing the point i
think we actually ought to zoom out a
little bit
okay i think it's perfectly right to
make really basic arguments here it's
wrong to kill
people it's wrong to murder people it's
wrong to kill babies it's wrong if
you're going to cite a bunch of bs to
justify your right to abortion just then
you need us to recognize
you you need you need to allow us to
point out that abortion negates all of
those rights if you're going to call it
reproductive health you've got to let us
explain how it's actually the opposite
of reproduction and the opposite of
health you can make really it's kind of
like th there's this meme of the iq
curve you know at the bottom at the
bottom it's like the really dumb guy
with a really low iq and he just goes
like duh it's wrong to kill babies duh
and then in the middle there's like the
really the the midwit types and they say
well actually no you have a right to
bodily autonomy and to establish this
and to do this and the 14th amendment
implies that you have a and that this
amendment replies you have a right to
privacy and therefore you can kill your
baby blah blah right and it's all these
egghead idiots from like yale law school
and then you get to the really top end
of the iq curve and it's this real
genius type guy and he just goes
it's wrong to kill babies it's just
wrong it's just right it actually is
that simple but you're going to hear a
lot more of these crazy arguments as we
get closer you're going to see it on snl
there was one of the weird not that i
watch snl okay no one watches snl
anymore but this was making the rounds
there was a sketch
that i guess was supposed to be funny
but i'm not even sure was supposed to be
funny about
abortion because the libs are so worried
that this supreme court case could lead
to the overturning of roe v wade and
planned parenthood b casey that one of
the cat i don't know their names anymore
but one of the cast members from snl
came on as a clown
to defend
the right to abortion
did you know one in three clowns will
have a clown abortion in her lifetime
you don't cause they don't tell you they
don't even know how to talk to other
clowns about it because when they do
talk about it if you were a clown who
wasn't the victim of something sad like
clown says they think your clown
abortion wasn't a righteous clown
abortion i mean what the dick is that
pull my finger no laugh i need it i need
you to laugh so hard like the way i
laugh when the doctor asked if i got
pregnant on the way over to the clinic
because i wasn't very far along and that
is one of my favorite jokes to this day
i love that joke it's such a good joke
not like a funny ha ha joke but like a
funny you're not an awful person and
your life is an over now joke the best
kind a honkahonka
good board and in the waiting room they
had a little guest book where all the
clowns could write their clown abortion
story for the next pound to read it so
she wouldn't feel so alone
here's my truth
i know i wouldn't be a clown on tv here
today if it weren't for the abortion i
had the day before my 23rd birthday
clowns have been helping each other and
their pregnancy since the caves it's
gonna happen so it ought to be safe
legal and accessible
we will not go back to the alley i mean
the last thing anyone wants is a bunch
of dead clowns in a dark alley
this is so
sad
so i guess they're tr
i guess it's supposed to be funny you
know then the clash when she says clown
she's just referring to women and i
guess it's supposed to be
is it supposed to be funny or is it that
the new hannah gadsby type of humor
which is
it's the new comedy it's called tragedy
it's really sad and weird
this woman is saying i'm really happy
with my decision and i'm glad she seems
to be insinuating that she herself had
an abortion at 23.
and she she's saying i'm okay with it
and i'm really happy with it and it was
a great decision but she doesn't seem
okay does she she seems like the
opposite of okay she seems psychotic she
seems like it led her to have a mental
freaking breakdown that's happening on
tv right now
she says you know if i if i didn't have
an abortion i wouldn't be a clown on tv
right now
right you'd have a good life instead of
a bad life instead instead of literally
being a clown and humiliating yourself
and degrading yourself and having a
mental breakdown on tv
you would have a good life with a family
and i'm so people make bad decisions i
know i know many not many i know a lot
of women
who have had abortions some have had
multiple abortions and it
it harms them
harms the baby obviously it harms them
and there are so many lies about
abortion in the culture
that they don't realize how bad it's
going to be and you're going to end up
like this lunatic woman on tv
who is clearly clearly still trying to
process this trauma that she that
happened to her
and that
she perpetrated as well
she's obviously not okay and she's
trying to justify with these bogus lines
about how lots of women died in back
alley abortions it's just not it's
completely made up that did not happen
that dr bernard nathanson was one of the
abortion leaders who pushed these
statistics about all these women and
back alley abortions dying didn't happen
statist it was very few as a couple to a
few dozen who would die in the year
before roe versus wade before medical
technology was advanced and
roughly the same
you roughly had the same likelihood of
dying from a legal abortion and an
illegal abortion so it was just complete
bs do you want it it was a really
illustrative moment do you want to end
up
like that woman do you want to end up as
a crazy clown on tv or do you want to
end up as a stable happy normal person
you know
so we all have problems we all carry a
lot of tension in our lives
you want to remedy some of that physical
tension i would strongly recommend you
check out home edicts since i was but a
wee young lad i've had some back
problems okay it affects a lot of people
and i never knew exactly how to fix it
you know you do this stretch use this
product well i've got an amazing
solution home medics they've got a whole
line of massage products from a massage
gun with built-in hot and cold
technology to a massage cushion that
lets you lie down or sit up depending on
your therapeutic needs that's the that's
my favorite one actually they've also
got a three-in-one foot massager with
vibrations so powerful that it loosens
the muscles in your legs and lower back
i have one complaint though about
homedics and this is a real i want to be
as transparent with you as i can be
homemedics is so good that if you bring
it into for instance your office at the
daily wire your staff members will steal
it from you this is my only complaint i
love my home medics i love the foot
massager i love the the massage cushion
except i don't have it anymore because
my freaking staff members stole it from
me it's just that good i guess i need to
get another one luckily they're not very
expensive so you can you can get more
whether you're dealing with chronic pain
or just looking to help your muscles
recover from a workout we've got good
news right now if you go to
homemedics.com knowles use promo code
knowles you will receive a free portable
phone sanitizer when you buy 100 or more
in massage products sixty dollar value
h-o-m-e-d-i-c-s
dot com slash knowles use the promo code
knowles for your free portable phone
sanitizer with a hundred dollar massager
purchase last week the daily wire made
one of the biggest announcements we will
probably ever make
and it is that we are filing a lawsuit
against the federal government
the daily wires lawsuit was filed by the
dillon law group and alliance defending
freedom in the sixth circuit court of
appeals
the lawsuit alleges that the biden
administration lacks constitutional and
statutory authority to issue the
employer mandate
uh that everyone take the the
fouchyouchi uh it also alleges that the
mandate failed to meet the requirements
for issuing a rule
taking effect immediately without the
normal process of considering public
comments the biden administration has
warned that companies that do not comply
with this federal overreach can be fined
as much as 136 thousand dollars per
violation
basically no company can weather that
that's why we need your help if you're
not a member yet please consider joining
us today if you go to dailywire.com
subscribe enter code do not comply at
checkout you'll receive 25 off your
membership you will be fighting this
unconstitutional mandate with us we
appreciate your help and we will not
comply you know as we're trying to churn
a lot of stuff here we're trying to put
out a lot of content okay we've got some
more exciting news here we're launching
daily wire now
which means you'll be able to stream all
your favorite daily wire shows on vizio
smartcast tune in to watch candace
discuss current events with guests
ranging from donald trump to dana white
catch one of your favorite hosts i don't
know i'm not naming names very possibly
yours truly there's always something
interesting to stream watch daily wire
now exclusively on vizio watch free plus
streaming app on channel 162 to access
the content you love 24 hours a day
seven days a week only on vizio
smartcast we'll be right back with a lot
more
a lot of problems in the country
economic problems national security
problems social problems
we don't have trust in our institutions
anymore a lot of a lot of issues we're
naming shifts after u.s navy ships after
sexual predators and cult leader
defenders
we got a lot of problems how do we fix
some senator josh hawley
an increasingly interesting and
serious-minded member of the united
states senate
has
a solution
young men need to stop wasting their
time on porn in video games
what's a man well a man is a father a
man is a husband a man of somebody who
takes responsibility as conservatives
we've got to call men back to
responsibility we've got to say that
spending your time not working and we
have more and more men who are not
working spending your time on video
games spending your time watching porn
online while doing nothing is not good
for you your family or this country
you know people are going to make fun of
him and call him the church lady and say
oh here we go we're going to hear about
the video games and the violence and the
porn and okay here we okay church lady
but of course josh hawley is completely
right
wasting your time hours and hours and
hours on video games looking at porn i'm
not i don't want to sound holier than
that really quite the opposite i want to
point out that
virtually every man in the country at
least at some point has done these
things has wasted time on
on screens i mean even if it's beyond
the the video games or beyond porn which
is kind of extreme example even just
you know mindlessly watching tv for 10
hours a day or whatever you know just
kind of turning off your brain turning
off your productivity turning off your
sense of responsibility and diligence
that's a really bad thing and it's it
there are increasing temptations for
that in society and we got to resist it
because it's not good for anyone it's
not good for you it's not good for your
family it's not good for society and
what what this is really getting at is
something beyond just do the right thing
don't do the wrong thing
be virtuous don't be vicious
pursue good don't be sinful it's
there's actually a techn technological
political problem here which is that
we are moving into
virtual
reality we're living more and more of
our lives virtually rather than in the
real world you know i i mentioned the
harvey milk stuff and the navy ship
being launched by a man who thinks that
he's a woman we talk about
transgenderism
a lot on the right
why and it's the most controversial
thing we talk about
i was attacked at a speech at university
of missouri kansas city not for any of
the
actually somewhat controversial things
i've said at speeches before but for the
most basic one which is that a man is
not a woman why what what is that issue
about well james pulas one of the
writers over at claremont has
this theory that i i think is correct
that
transgenderism is less about
sex as an end unto itself and more a
foothold into transhumanism
meaning it's a way to transcend our
ordinary human limits in the real world
and and basically all become weird
cyborg robot type things and i do think
there's quite a lot to that the denial
of one's body the denial of the
significance of one's body is obviously
the centerpiece of
transhumanism and to use a new word that
was coined by mark zuckerberg last week
the metaverse
imagine
you put on your glasses or headset and
you're instantly in your home space
it has parts of your physical home
recreated virtually it has things that
are only possible virtually and it has
an incredibly inspiring view of whatever
you find most beautiful
hey are you coming yeah just gotta find
something to wear
all right perfect
[Music]
oh hey mark hey what's going on
hey guys we're all hanging out in the
the metaverse and if you didn't see the
video one of the so it's all these
people who have avatars that look like
themselves
one looks to be basically a video of of
a girl then some are more cartoonish and
then one guy is just a
he is just a giant cartoon robot because
you can also choose that if you don't
like your body you can just
portray yourself as someone else
entirely and we know this at the most
basic level you know this with your
profile picture on twitter or on
facebook it can either be a real picture
of you or it can be just some random
picture of someone else and you say okay
this is going to be my new avatar and
what zuckerberg is announcing and he
tied this into his announcement that
facebook is changing its name to meta he
said there's going to be this whole new
experience where we're going to live in
the metaverse we're going to put on our
virtual reality headset and we're going
to hold our virtual reality controllers
and we're not going to go to the bar
anymore and we're not going to go to our
friend's house anymore we're going to
sit in our pods and we're going to play
a really really elaborate video game
with our friends and it's going to be
great what if your friend is on the
other side of the world well you can
instantly connect with them you can hang
out with them not in reality but in the
metaverse
doesn't that sound fun
doesn't it i mean to me it sounds like a
horror movie it sounds like a 1980s
dystopian horror movie that's about five
seconds away
from the terminator
but to a lot of people i think it sounds
great oh yeah i've got you know my
friends now look we don't even go to the
office anymore i don't really need to
see people we can just
we'll just communicate virtually and
that'll be a lot of a lot of fun my
friend spencer clavin also at claremont
made this point which is
what is so wrong about this the thing
that we all know we all kind of have a
hunch that something's really wrong
about it but maybe we can't quite put
our finger on it
is that
the move from reality to the metaverse
is tantamount to us saying
who wants to live in this world created
by god when we can live in a world
created and controlled by mark
zuckerberg
right we we live in reality right now
we've got our physical bodies and we go
and move in three dimensions and
this is a world that was created and is
sustained constantly by god but a lot of
people don't like this world because
there's suffering in this world there's
pain in this world there are limits
there are social mores and and taboos
some we live in a society and not
everyone agrees with us in that society
so let's get rid of that world let's get
rid of that fallen broken oh that oh
that world that god made let's live in
zuckerberg's world
where if you don't like people you just
never have to see them even if you live
right next door to them right you log
into the metaverse you'll never have to
see you'll only see the people you
choose to see
and if you have certain affinities and
desires you can only see people who
share those affinities and desires and
if you don't like your body you think
you're a little overweight you think
you're a little short you think you're a
man but you're really a woman or vice
versa well you can just you just change
your body
you you really can for all intents and
purposes in the metaverse become if
you're a man you can become a woman
because your body doesn't matter anymore
isn't that great a lot of people will be
tempted to that
delusion fantasy is a real temptation
that everyone
deals with
but
if you're coming down on the question
though do you want to go to the
metaverse do you want to stay in reality
i guess the question is this who do you
trust more god or mark zuckerberg
pretty easy answer for me and i don't
mean to deny the actual suffering and
difficulties of this world there are
many of them you know death decay
injustice
childhood cancer
there's no there's no childhood cancer
in the metaverse right i mean i guess
characters could just disappear but
there's no those kind of
really difficult hard things just don't
exist there
whereas they do exist in the real world
okay but who do you trust more god or
mark zuckerberg for me it's an easy
answer but a lot of people are going to
trust mark zuckerberg which is why these
guys these tech
you can't even call them oligarchs
they're like demigods at this point
they are they are taking more power
there there is a greater asymmetry of
power between them and other people on
earth than has existed basically
anywhere in the history of the world
and they're coming after your kids okay
won't some to sound like the church lady
won't somebody please think of the
children
sesame street moving on from the
metaverse to the traditional boob tube
sesame street streaming through the good
old tv is is trying to
convince your kid trying to market to
your kid
the kovid vaccine
oh oh no i made the business for my
covenant vaccine my mommy and my puppy
took me to get it this morning
oh rosita that's great getting the coba
vaccine is a great way to stay healthy
see my mommy and my puppy said that it
will help keep me my friends my
neighbors my abuela all healthy your
parents are absolutely right you know
covet vaccines are now available for
children
five years and older and the more people
who get them the better we're going to
be able to help stop the spread of covid
and keep everyone healthy
this is sick this is really really sick
and i think a lot of people do not
appreciate how sick it is because i
think what a lot of people see is
yeah the libs are pushing the vaccine
and so they're doing it through any
means they can they're doing it on tv
they're doing it in the news they're
doing it through influencers they're
just going to try to sell it right okay
sure i get that
but sesame street is a show that is
almost exclusively watched by children
maybe a parent happens to be sitting in
the room but it's a show for kids
are are kids now supposed to be making
their own medical decisions is that
what's going on
i don't
last i checked it's not up to
five-year-olds to make their own medical
decisions it's up to their parents
right shouldn't you be marketing this on
parents shows you know cnn for instance
shouldn't sanjay gupta is over there
shouldn't cnn be saying hey parents
here's why you need to get your kids
vaccinated no because
the these people know that parents some
parents are going to say no actually my
kids don't really face a great risk from
the coronavirus and this drug is pretty
experimental and you know there have
been side effects some of which have
been deadly and documented by the fda
and cdc so no i'm we're just not going
to do that we're going to wait a little
bit and the libs really want to get
everyone to take the fouchyache and so
they're going to go directly to the kids
as if the kids are a higher authority
here
kids are idiots by the way right that's
the kind of the definition of a kid is
they don't know anything that's why they
have to go to school and be educated
isn't that the reason they're watching
sesame street in the first place because
they don't know anything so they need to
learn their abcs but now you're telling
me a kid is so sophisticated that he
knows better how to make these complex
medical decisions than his own parents
that's what they do though
it gets to something else we talked
about on on friday which is the
different ways you can look at politics
for the left and for libertarians the
basic unit of politics is the individual
everything is about the atomized
individual
for conservatives the basic unit of
politics is the family
those are very different ways of viewing
the world okay
but the the hyper focus on the
individual means of course they got to
market it to kids and by the way of
course kids can choose if they want to
get a transgender surgery which
increasingly many of them are and
they're going to come to regret it but
that's their individual choice and the
family has no role here because the
family is the actual
impediment
to
the left taking control right the family
is the actual structural obstacle
that that obstinate little
atom of society
that will stop the left from totally
taking control
now fortunately forget about sesame
street we are getting some good news on
this vaccine mandate a bunch of states
including my own state of tennessee are
suing the government so the daily wire
is suing the government in the sixth
circuit court of appeals we are making a
stand as an employer of a company with
more than 100 people
state attorneys general
including tennessee kentucky idaho
kansas ohio oklahoma and west virginia
at last count
are suing the biden administration for
its vaccine mandate in the
in the uh court of appeals as well now
the the lesson here is we all need to
band together okay it's not enough the
daily wire could have sat back and said
you know i'm sure the states are going
to challenge this this unconstitutional
vaccine mandate so we're just going to
stay back look we're putting a huge
target on our backs by suing the biden
administration
where we're going to spend
some
insane amount of money fighting them
and we're opening ourselves up to a
liability that could basically bankrupt
the company but we're going to take a
stand anyway because we can't just leave
it up to the state attorneys general
we have got to fight back as private
employers too an individual should be
fighting back and community should be
fighting back and school districts
should be fighting back we all need to
band together here folks we're going to
join or die you band together or you
you win together or you lose
alone
and we're getting some really good news
on this by the way
because the fifth circuit court of
appeals has just given us some good news
yesterday
the fifth circuit court of appeals
is
issuing a stay for the vaccine mandate
quote because the petitions give cause
to believe there are grave statutory and
constitutional issues with the vaccine
mandate the mandate is hereby stayed
pending further action
by this court in other words
we called their bluff
the
fifth circuit court of appeals is the
the first step in this process where
they've said you you the the mandate is
is not gonna just proceed along
without any obstacle
we need to hear this out we need to find
out if this is constitutional or not so
until further notice this mandate is on
hold
now some of us you might request you
know i hate to say i told you so we
called this early on
early on when joe biden first made his
announcement about the mandate i thought
this has nothing to do with whether or
not he has the legal authority to to
send out this mandate
he kind of admitted that he didn't have
the legal authority early on so then he
used this bizarre workaround with the
occupational safety and health
administration that was then going to
use employers of
100 or more employees to try to push the
mandate and i said look the thing's
probably going to be struck down in
court
maybe it'll be upheld maybe it'll be
struck down
the biden administration doesn't care
they didn't even release the rule for
months after they made the announcement
what this was about
was bullying people pressuring people
and to get the vaccine because
between the time biden made his
announcement at the time osha actually
released the rules how many employee
employers forced their employees to get
the vaccine
how many tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands maybe
were forced to get it
between the time biden made his
announcement or osha sent out the rule
and the time a court potentially could
strike down the the mandate
it will be a moot point because all the
employers will already force the the
employees to get the jab
so they get struck down okay oh well too
bad
we all already did what we wanted you to
do anyway okay
oh shocks and so what's happening right
now with the daily wire and with these
state attorneys general is they're
calling the bluff they're saying okay
you're going to push this
unconstitutional mandate you're just
gonna hope we all go along with it
before it gets struck down okay
well we're gonna fight you in the court
as vigorously as we can to get a stay on
the mandate so okay now you gotta we
need an answer
before
we proceed any further we need an answer
is this constitutional
or not
i don't think this is helping biden
people always
try to cite these surveys and say the
the mandates are very popular and
vaccine mandates are really great well
if the vaccine mandates are so popular
why are
biden's poll numbers
through the bottom of the floor
right now joe biden's approval rating
according to a usa today and suffolk
poll is down to 38
38 as we close out 2021 and get into the
2022 midterm season that is
devastating for democrats
assuming that republicans stop them from
the most egregious sort of they're
cheating with the ballot harvesting and
election day turning into elections six
months and
you know
batches of 3 a.m ballots coming in by
the way there's a news story about that
in new jersey we'll get to that either
later or tomorrow but you know the usual
ways democrats cheat to steal elections
assuming we can
can work around that
if the elections were held today
republicans would sweep the country it's
not even i mean the democrat numbers are
pathetic on on basically every single
issue
so something needs to turn around for
the democrats and
actually i think that there's some
wisdom here that they can learn from
oh it hurts me to say it
from aoc
on the election front i actually think
we have good news as well i know that
virginia was a huge bummer and honestly
if anything
i think that the results show
the limits of trying to run a fully 100
super moderated campaign that does not
excite
speak to or energize a progressive base
and frankly we weren't even really
invited
to contribute on that race everyone's
making fun of aoc oh you crazy socialist
you know what you think that the the
democrats aren't radical enough they're
so radical their approval ratings are
are in the
they're approaching single digits they
just keep plummeting you know now 38 or
lower you're crazy aoc they no i think
she's right actually
i do think she's right i think one of
the problems that happened in virginia
not that terry mcauliffe is some radical
he's not he's a regular corporate
democrat
but he ran on
licking his finger putting it up in the
air figuring out which way the wind was
blowing and
glenn yunken who's also a fairly
moderate candidate but he ran on a
right-wing culture war campaign
especially by the end of that race he
ran on education critical race theory
transgender bathrooms loudoun county
schools that's what he ran on
red meat
serious important culture war issues
and aoc is looking at this and she's
saying why don't democrats do that they
probably should
you got to be careful with it it's not
just that you need to find the most
bloodthirsty far
extreme candidate and run that person
you've got to be careful with it if if
glenn younkin had run as donald trump in
northern virginia that probably would
not have worked you got but
if if glenn younkin had ran against
i don't know
if he had run on traditional marriage
and overturning obergefell and getting
rid of the new definition of marriage he
probably would have lost by a lot
you know if he'd run on that kind of a
social issue if he had run even on
abortion i think he probably would have
lost
but he found a culture war issue
that united a lot of people not just the
far right conservatives but the wine
moms and the suburbanites and all of
these people which is
don't teach terrible racial and sexual
theories to my kids
and that worked and i think i think
democrats could probably learn learn a
lot from that
right now though they're just running
on
the
they're just running on the ruling class
they're just saying yeah just trust us
we're doing great right now the energy
secretary for joe biden was asked what
what she has to say to people who are
worried about rising gas prices who are
worried about heating their homes and
filling their cars this winter and her
answer was to laugh at them
in sturgis michigan
it is
2.89 a gallon i guess that's better than
in california what is the grand home
plan to increase oil production in
america
oh my god
that is hilarious wood that i had the
magic wand on this as you know of course
oil is a global market it is controlled
by a cartel that cartel is called opec
and they made a decision yesterday that
they were not going to increase beyond
what they were already planning
you can't eat your home
you can't fill your car
that's the funniest joke i heard since
snl
it's the funny it's a clown world is
what we're living we're living in a
clown world where the ruling class is
increasingly divorced from reality and
that's really bad for our country when
our rulers don't have any kind of grip
on reality and they're laughing like a
bunch of clowns but i think the one
positive the one silver lining here is a
lot of americans across a lot of
different demographics are recognizing
that they have a much better hold on
reality than the ruling class does and
and the upcoming elections are going to
be about that it's not just going to be
about taxes going up and down it's not
just going to be about the normal
political issues it is going to be about
much more fundamental questions what is
our country who are we what do we stand
for what is true and what is false and
do we have to keep living in a clown
world i'm michael and also this michael
knowles shawl see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show the 5th
circuit court of appeals puts a hold on
joe biden's vaccine mandate a handful of
congressional republicans give democrats
a win on infrastructure and california
rewrites how math should be taught
that's today on the benchmark show give
it a listen